money
it's everywhere
but what happens when your bills get old
and need to be replaced by new ones that
means old cash needs to be destroyed
a lot of cash
this is not however the story of money
growing on trees but of trees
growing out of money well more like
vegetables
we are here at the federal reserve bank
in new orleans and this is where we
shred millions of dollars
my name is dean mortha i'm the lead
business analyst for cash services here
at the new orleans fed we are the
nation's bank our job is to make sure
that we have a supply of currency
also part of that is to ensure that we
remove unfit old dirty currency from
circulation so here on average we shred
about six million dollars in dirty money
every day
this could be for any number of reasons
it could be because the note has rips in
it holds and it tears in it
it could have tape on it it could have
graffiti written all over it we don't
want that note going back into
circulation if it has any sort of those
qualities will be shredded
what we used to do is take all of these
currency shreds and they would just wind
up his waste going to a landfill
now through a lot of work and effort we
finally figured out a way where we can
take these shreds and ultimately recycle
them
so all that green leaves the fed and
heads to a compost facility where it
turns into something quite useful
what you're looking at right now is 24
million dollars but the soil that it
creates will be priceless
my name is jonathan christian
we turn cash into soil
it is definitely one of our secret
ingredients
it's little in content but it's huge in
what it provides
currency that's deemed unfit it's
brought to our facility at wood
materials
from there we go through a simple
composting process where we convert that
into a healthy soil
our compost is used primarily by urban
farmers in the greater new orleans area
one of these farmers is simon minash and
this is a million dollar farm
we are making fresh local food
accessible
in new orleans
we've grown veggies herbs cucumbers
tomatoes and peppers
the vegetables we grow here are made out
of composted cash
it is very fulfilling to
be growing using a material that would
otherwise go to waste
one man's trash is another man's
treasure
and that's the story of how we grow
tomatoes
out of cash
you